la france se débat actuellement avec son
déficit de la sécurité sociale comment
faire en sorte que notre pays conserve
un système plus qu'enviable si l'on s'en
réfère par exemple aux états unis
reportage pascal golomer prises dans le
bras juanita cette habituée à sa dose
quotidienne de pilules et de comprimés
ce qu'elle n'a jamais accepté c'est le
montant de l'ordonance l'équivalent de
650 euros par mois elle devait payer de
sa poche
la sécu ne lui rembourse presque rien
c'est presque impossible à ce bras
d'acheter à la fois de quoi se nourrir
et de quoi se soigner
c'est vraiment dur elle a donc décidé
d'aller acheter les mêmes médicaments au
canada voisin où les prix sont
réglementés
sa facture a été divisé par quatre elle
n'est pas la seule à avoir fait ce choix
à la fédération des retraités du
minnesota
c'est le mot d'ordre achetez canadien
via les pharmacies sur internet
certes george bush vient de réformer le
système de la sécu pour que les
personnes âgées les plus démunis les
plus malades soient mieux remboursés que
par le passé mais pour les autres rien
de changé le prix des médicaments
restent fixés par les laboratoires aux
mains ce que veut le gouvernement c'est
améliorer la couverture santé
mais en même temps signe un chèque en
blanc aux labos pharmaceutiques et notre
crainte c'est qu'en les laissant faire
ce qu'ils veulent et l'esc de mettre
notre système de santé en faillite
cette réforme en tout cas ne change rien
au sort des 20 millions de salariés
américains qui n'ont aucune couverture
santé pas de sécu ni d'assurance privés
payés par leur employeur ce soir là dans
l'arrière cour d'un café de minneapolis
les employés d'un cinéma de la ville
évoque presque en secret la création
d'un syndicat parce qu'ils veulent
revendiquer justement cette assurance
santé qui leur fait tant défaut avec ce
que je gagne je ne pourrai jamais me
payer moi même mon assurance santé tout
ce que je peux faire c'est aller vite et
d'avoir un accident de voiture où il est
tombé par terre dans la rue une
assurance santé pour tous c'est l'un des
principaux thèmes de campagne de john
kerry le candidat démocrate à la
présidentielle
mais personne ici n'imagine que le
système aussi imparfait aussi injuste
soit ils puissent être réformée du jour
au lendemain